ramita Hut juniors it's been a little
over a year in a lot of videos since
then but I think it's about time I
returned to the world of dressing up in
spandex and awkwardly posing in public
spaces like I own the damn place however
I've been a little hesitant to do a
video on the suit for a particularly big
reason I didn't film myself making it
but to be fair most of the process is
the same as the last suit I made the
biggest difference is that I took more
time with this one I had a more solid
creative vision for how I wanted it to
turn out I had tons more talented
cosplay kids from around the globe
helping me with the parts I struggled
with and I got to do everything with
this suit that I didn't have the
resources or skill to pull off with the
first one if you don't mind the fact
that most the progression will be shown
through still images taken on my crappy
phone then I can kinda still make a
tutorial on the suit in fact to make up
for it a little
I bought a pre sewn extra suit and made
that into a Mark Bagley spider-man so I
could film the process for that one and
fill in some of the blanks so this is
kind of like two Spider Man suits for
the price of one but we'll be focusing
mainly on the junior junior suit since
that one's all homemade that being said
I present you John Romita Jr spider-man
I know how much everyone loves his art
but like I actually just love his art
it's pretty heavily stylized the
proportions and shapes of some things
look a little blocky or anatomically
incorrect but does everything have to be
hyper realistic Greg land horn tracings
I don't hear anyone make these
complaints about Mike Mignola's art but
his isn't that far off plus the best
spider-man cartoon has a pretty blocky
and unrealistic art style y'all are just
me bad comic art is canceled that part
isn't joke it's actually canceled
[Music]
anyhoo I was tooling around with the
idea of doing another suit for the past
year or so and my buddy Jacob suggested
making it based on the works of a
specific comic artist which would to add
an extra layer of challenge but also
make it look pretty damn neat in the end
he himself sewed together a suit from
scratch based on the early did Co Spidey
using some techniques from my first
tutorial as well as some of his own
unique skills so this adorable little
Peter Parker II knucklehead sketched up
some templates for the logos based on
some panels from the JM s comics and I
got to work this time I bought some
slightly better body suits online turns
out you can find these on Amazon for
really low prices instead of waiting for
a Halloween store to stock them like a
loser I think the material for these
ones is just nicer to work with it's
really stretchy and nice on the skin
sometimes comfort is just as important
as the look maybe some days you want to
just use the suit as pyjamas I'll put it
on flex on them a little like a doofus
sketch out the lines for ROI or cut the
red portions and then chop it up with
some scissors this portion the tutorial
is pretty much the same as the original
suit I made so go check out that video
first the only major differences that I
stopped segmenting the gloves from the
rest of the red on the arms this time I
had the idea of sewing it all the way up
the arm and just having the gloves
stretch over like a hood that way you
can take them off and hide the suit on
your clothes and scorching hot weather
and die of heatstroke from wearing to me
layers but you can also have it look
more connected no one will even notice
that they're removable plus you don't go
worried about losing them or sewing on
like six extra snap buttons also make
sure to mark the spot where you'll draw
the spider logo on you while you're
wearing it and standing upright on my
first suit I put the logo on while lying
down so it's a little too low on my
chest this time I said screw it and
didn't hem the red parts anywhere
because spandex doesn't really need it
and it's reducing material for you to
work with you're still concerned about
the edges fraying you just give them one
of these you know a decent amount of
this video is stuff you guys have
already seen or heard from me so do you
mind if I take some brief intermissions
to give some shoutouts for cool people
I've worked with lately
of course you don't mind thanks for
understanding if you're looking for a
new gameplay channel to watch since a
lot of other ones have disappeared
lately my good buddy governor yes that's
his real name has started one of his
roommate and his girlfriend they're
really funny honest and profound people
governor's a bit of a Renaissance man
actually because him and his girlfriend
Shawna Wright draw and published this
neat indie comic and they let me buy
some ad space in it she's done some
really crazy awesome artwork too for a
few professional projects as well as
just for fun and guv has done some voice
acting work as well as appearing on an
episode of that show at midnight for his
epic reading of Frankenstein I recently
recorded a let's play of Marvel Ultimate
Alliance with them so go check it out
well telling me the channel has taken
six live since its inception no one
knows how or why but people keep dying
okay have you ever seen final
destination it's like that but YouTube
videos come out at the end I can't be
mad at Thor he did way more than
star-lord did well you know why it's
know why star Lords a hero he's because
he bought us one extra Avengers movie
he's too strong back on track the only
part of the suit you got a hem up really
is the neck on the red and blue suits
since that part gets stretched out a lot
then for the absurdly annoying and
difficult task of pinning the red piece
to the blue suit underneath remember not
to pin this part so we can make that
glove opening there's no shame in having
a second person help you with this it's
a giant pain in the tokus and my life
would be so much easier if I had a
mannequin with my exact body proportions
to take out some self-esteem issues on
and used for cosplays once this thing
has just become a red and blue Iron
Maiden death trap full of pointy parts
very carefully peel yourself out of it
and then get to work on sewing the chest
and belt on there I can't remember how
on earth we managed to sew the arms on
this thing the first time with the
sewing machine so that part I just did
by hand on this suit it's really as
simple as just running some stitches up
and down the arm a few times while you
wear it making sure to tie them off well
just don't pull too hard on this glove
hood thing or you'll stiff these riches
on accident all right you're done if you
want to be PlayStation 1 spider-man or
maybe you can just do the webs on the
gloves and mask if you want to be meme
fodder but the rest of us still got a
lot of work to do time to move on to the
most annoying and painful experience of
your cosplay career webs so I got this
washable marker thing that's really
handy it shows up decently well on red
fabric and it comes off from just making
contact with water so I sketched out the
web lines on the entire suit with this
thing I looked at a lot of john romita
jr. art
different angles to find the exact
amount of columns on the chest and arms
sometimes it's a little inconsistent but
on average it's about six on the chest
and four on the arms I did kind of mess
up a little on some of the horizontal
webs but that's the beauty of erasable
markers this layer of webs is really
just to make the top layer look good and
it won't be the final product I guess
this just generally feels more relaxing
than using a sharpie because you don't
get a do-over with that now on to doing
the puffy shiny webs I really wanted
this with my original suit but it was
too afraid of screwing it up but
sometimes you got to just admit to
yourself Xavier all you ever do is screw
things up who cares just go for it
ramita drawers the web's very square and
grid like while on this bagley suit I
did I noticed that they're much less of
a uniform size and shape and curve a lot
more up towards the neck while bulging
at the chest so about puff painting use
this brand it's the only good kind for
this this is going to be ten shades of
annoying so brace yourself and the time
it took me to paint all the webs on this
suit my girlfriend and I watch the
entire Friday the 13th series and every
Harry Potter movie in two separate
marathons calculate the amount of hours
that dates plus like three or four extra
ones for one she fell asleep and I kept
working on it anyway because I became
obsessed with getting it done to the
point of permanently damaging my sleep
schedule and personal relationships with
the workers of jo-ann fabrics make sure
these web lines don't come off or start
the crack you got to do multiple layers
one of which you really just mash into
the fabric so it dies the insides of the
threads this one's kind of impossible to
get out so if the layers on the top fall
off this one will always be there then
you do another layer of the puffy web on
the top to give it some dimension and
some shine then one more if you're super
paranoid about it
I can't exactly paint this while it's on
me so I stuff the pillow and cutting
board inside the suit to stretch it out
to about the same size as a human torso
since I don't have any of those on hand
for the limbs in the neck you can just
shove empty plastic bottles in there or
towels or both whatever works for just
keeping it fluffed out so the web's can
dry in the right shape while you're
working on that tedious task you can
listen to this awesome spider-man themed
podcast by my friend Dan Givaudan he's a
writer for The Hollywood Reporter as
well as one of the biggest spider-man
fans of all time his show gets some
incredibly big names for
guest interviews but somehow his views
and sub count don't ever seem to climb
it's maddening how great this podcast is
but it gets no attention
if you like any of these people and want
to know a little bit more about them
he's interviewed all of them on the show
plus he does reviews of every issue of
Spidey's so if you want to know which
ones are worth checking out
give him a listen who knows maybe I'll
be on that show someday all right I hope
you left a space for that chest logo you
can really make it based on how any
Spidey artist draws the logo pretty much
every artist does a different one and
it's fun to celebrate all their unique
little signatures on the design no two
guys draw it exactly alike and I like to
think of each art style as its own
individual costume that Spidey wore
there's a world of difference between
Ditko McFarlane and del Otto yet they're
all very clearly just Spidey as I said
earlier my pal Jacob drew these stencils
for the front back logos based on the
waiver meet a junior dozen so I printed
them off at about the right size for the
front logo I cut the shape of it into a
piece of cardboard laid it on the suit
then used a brush to get all of the puff
paint to sit really flat on the surface
kind of like how I did the Ben Riley
hoodie except I did it on a cutting
board this time instead of exacto knife
in the [ __ ] out of my poor mother's
kitchen table after that I went over the
outline of the logo with the tube of
puff paint so the edges look a little
more defined and catch the light better
I think it turned out pretty good don't
mind the fact that I screwed up the web
pattern on top of the logo I just put
some red paint on there and now you came
and tell I'm not an incompetent fraud I
swear I'm super good at this you guys
please don't leave me I need you back to
the back logo this time I decided you to
skip all that nonsense with the
cardboard and pin the paper with the
stencil straight to the suit while the
cutting board and pillow over inside it
turns out that works pretty well what
doesn't work pretty well as this rival
brand of puff paint it was extremely
watery and hard to work with and left
the suit looking more stained than
painted even after multiple layers it
just had more of a brownish muddy look
than a red so after it dried for a few
hours I went back over the same area
with the superior brand of puff paint on
a couple of layers and it looked way
better this is something I'd recommend
doing instead of cutting the shape out
of some fabric and
ruling it on I really just got lucky the
first time and that could have easily
fallen apart or become a mess this way
there's just nothing to fall off or get
old the paint's not going anywhere
adding souls to the suit was uniquely
tricky but just makes it so much more
authentic and practical if you pull it
off and realize this until way after the
fact but the water shoes I got for this
looked like they have a web pattern on
the bottom so what you do is you get a
water shoe that's about one size too
small because it needs to be rather
tight for this to work then you get a
foam pad I found these ones they're
supposed to be like arch supports for
your shoes if you're an old man who
feels like your shoes don't have a good
enough arch support arch simple I cut
that out to be about the right size to
fit into the water shoe then slid it
into the boot from the costume I put
some plastic bags on so I didn't glue
myself into the shoe and then use this
stuff called shoe goo which is some of
the sturdiest adhesive you can buy just
short of web fluid then you can cut the
inside of the sole on the bottom of the
boot with the stuff press down hard on
it and then just wait for a little while
until it's starting to dry give it about
20 minutes or something then you take it
off very carefully and let it just sit
for about a day if you want to make the
soles a little less noticeable on the
suit you can try and make them red with
this stuff called plastidip it's like
spray-painting on a layer of rubber and
it's really resistant to wear and tear
it's super cool to be able to walk
around pretty much anywhere in the suit
and now it's pretty comfortable to run
in to does it break the immersion a
little that his feet can stick through a
half-inch of rubber sole yeah but not as
much as him wearing nothing but a layer
of spandex while he walks around on hot
rooftops covered in gravel or alleys
full of broken glass speaking of broken
glass you can hear the sound of my voice
on a gaming themed podcast called Auto
saving the day we're me and two other
more entertaining guys talk about
upcoming games from the perspective of
comic fans we even pitch our own ideas
for games the host is my pal Diego
Rivera who has his own channel where he
reviews comic book games and whatnot
with his own unique spin on it
panels to pixels does a great job of
editorials and opinion pieces on comic
games as well this content is really
upbeat and energetic so if I'm taking
too long to upload and you want some
similar style of content in the meantime
they've got you covered
think of them as the Sub Zero and
reptile to my score
similar but still unique and worth
checking out putting the web's on these
boots is a goddamn nightmare and I
couldn't bend my leg in any position
make it easier you might need another
person for this one or like to just
stuff it with towels in the relative
shape of a leg or put bottles into it or
break into a department store at the
mall and robbed the place at gunpoint
demanding just a single mannequin and
become labeled in the media's some kind
of perverse fiend then right into the
local news station a manifesto
constructed newspaper clippings in which
you tell them that you're just a
cosplayer and hard times and you only
did an inappropriate things to the
mannequin once after just a few drinks
one night and that wasn't the sole
intention of taking it which they'll
misconstrue is you saying you intended
to steal further mannequins causing mall
security to carry Tasers and shotguns
resulting in a misunderstanding where an
elderly woman named Gladys attempts to
remove a jacket from a mannequin and is
massacred by the guards causing you to
feel extreme guilt and return the
mannequin to set things right only for
it to be revealed that they sometimes
saw the old ones that they don't need
anymore for like $20 and all the
bloodshed could have been avoided
culminating in your supervillain origin
story where you become a mannequin
themed bank robber with no face but
insanely trendy choices of clothing and
limited poseability of your joints
anyway just stitch some snap buttons on
the boots and they stay right up
I guess the suits done Jacob made me
this badass mask to complete the John
Romita Jr look and it's pretty amazing
pretty much my favorite part of the suit
I found out he was working on a John
Romita senior mask and bought it from
him right away because I couldn't let
anyone else have something so perfect he
was gracious enough to also explain his
process behind making them for us
take it away boy oh okay Jacob what are
you doing right now in this little video
tutorial yes all right so this is um boy
I don't know what I'm gonna round doing
[ __ ] for anyway no talking to the camera
but we're not using that audience so I
got a Sharpie in my hand I got my iPad
underneath this sheet of notebook paper
I'm just drawing out this template that
I made on there so all right so you got
this little thingamajig here you're
gonna trace it onto that that foam stuff
yeah right I got my sharpie I put the
[ __ ] paper down and I basically just
yeah I draw all the [ __ ] over it so that
the same image is on the foam afterwards
and then and then here's another video
of you doing it yeah sorry to do it from
two angles
you doing the thing you can see if you
can see my unfinished unstoppable
spider-man suit in the background of
this one it's over there oh yeah it's
over there in the corner hanging up
overhanging don't know what unstoppable
spider-man is and they're cretins for it
unstoppable spider-man it's [ __ ] it's
pretty cool man
he's got the black suit right now it's
pretty neato anyway here's me cutting
some [ __ ] home it's so so this is the
this is my garage this is the inside of
my garage here I got some Plasti Dip
it's basically this rubber coating that
goes on like spray paint on ya that
people use it for cars yeah so that
shit's not going anywhere so you're
gonna want to use your Plasti Dip on the
foam frames that you've cut out you know
if you're just going for classic
spider-man eyes just use the black
plasti dip and you're good you can just
move on from there but if you're wanting
to make a pair of like miles lenses or
something where they got to be like red
you know different color do the Plasti
Dip first because it'll prime it because
spray paint likes to eat away at foam
and once you got that on there you can
spray paint it any color you want and it
looks real good alright so here you are
you're putting on this Gorilla Glue
stuff this stuff is yeah that this you
don't glue is so powerful I have yeah it
also still like okay I I tried to glue a
mask let like some mask lenses on to my
face shell and it got so stuck that I
actually had to rip the plastic on the
face shot there's just a just a chunk
taken out of it
because it was so powerful that glue is
never coming off ever I remember one
time I I was fixing like a [ __ ] beer
cozy or something from my dad with it
and I used like a little bit too much
and the chemical reaction that happened
when the two were like fusing together
the heat that formed from it was enough
to actually make like the foam in the
beer cozy smoke oh my god that's awesome
I saw it was like oh okay so you get
this stuff it's like called a perforated
vinyl it's like this plastic sticker
kind of thing put some of that on some
plastic and cut out the shape you need
and glue it to the frames and then you
got you got it something that looks a
little bit like this depending
what shape you got here turn it around
[ __ ] past me what the [ __ ] you doing
around [ __ ] long show us big okay
show us the front yeah go yeah working
that looks nice doesn't I cool that's on
my mask
I put I'm wearing that right now you're
wearing it right now no I'm not wearing
it right now I it's it's it's alright
alright here's a video of MIOSHA face
reveal so before you glue your pocket on
you're gonna want to paint you're gonna
want to paint the wefts on your mask
because I keep trying to do that it
after is in the paint in me so don't do
it make sure you do the web's first you
idiots alright okay cuz what I do is I
kind of like press the applicator to the
fabric so it really soaks into the end
of it it's just not yeah it's it's
stained into the fabric the way that I
do it it there will be a bit of a stain
but there's always the chance of on the
outer like top part that's raised and
breaking eventually if you stretch it
too much and you'll have to repaint it
after that it's not that of a deal if it
happens because it's an easy fix I guess
alright last but not least is attaching
these lenses to zoom ass here's a video
of me doing that from this looks like it
was filmed at night and this man so yeah
you can't really see come a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
standing in front of the camera
basically [ __ ] out of the way past ya
you're gonna want to use a little I got
an old gift card right here that I'm
using a smear around the glue cuz you
don't need that much of it so I just
basically put like a drop on the end and
smear it around to get the the coverage
I need and I start at the inner corner
and then you just kind of flatten it out
yeah I start at the inner corner of the
lens wear it like touches the nose
almost and and then I just kind of move
all the way to the outer corner okay so
something else to note for the audience
if you have a mannequin head that you're
doing this on please for the love of God
put some plastic on it because you
because that glue will attach the mask
to the mannequin head when you rip the
mask off there will be styrofoam stuck
to the inside of the mask it'll be like
a [ __ ] it'll be like the symbiote
suit with cardboard on the inside of it
you don't want that
[ __ ] again oh why do you gotta bring up
these painful memories that suits in the
trash now it got peed on oh yeah my I
got a cat and he was like eight weeks
old and then he peed on it cuz he was
like what's this thing laying in the
corner were known what's this trash
thing with a spider on it the gross
spider on the crotch it was just coated
and cat pee I just I I had to get rid of
it anyway that's how Jacob does masks
thank you for letting us in on your
process and showing us how you do that
voodoo that you do hopefully you'll be
in these these the cosplay tutorials
from this point forward just like little
bits like this since you are kind of
like my biggest helper with these now
since my mom was like I'm not doing them
anymore I give up you're done they're
yours I'm so tired of it and I was like
okay yeah I mean I've how many masks do
you have for me now you've got a lot of
those I've got five now five masks from
you oh hell yeah man I'm your best
customer yeah I think I got I keep
coming back I'll be making masks with no
particular person in mind I'm just
making a mild one or that Romita one
that I was making in that video and I
was just like man this is coming out
pretty good look at this picture Xavier
he's like check your PayPal cuz I need
it I can't let anyone else have it's
mine anyway thank you so much this was
great I'm gonna get back to doing the
scripted voiceover now thank you Jacob
you're the best see ya love you little
brother
mom and if you don't feel like going
through all that you can just buy one of
these from him directly and let him take
care of the hard part with results like
this you know it's worth the price plus
these things are pretty damn durable
unless you get a battle damaged one
which he also makes just for posterity's
sake I did try my hand at making my own
mask with this process and I liked how
it turned out so there you go and what
lesson have we learned today kids no
matter who you are or how hard you work
out or how good of shape you're in
someone will always think you look
chubby in spandex so stop trying to
please people and just dress how you
like sorry for interrupting the video so
many times but there's not a lot of
different stuff about the process with
the suits I just want
show some gratitude for the cool people
who I work with and help them out since
they're all so underrated
and speaking of underrated never on lay
off Johnny boy over here there's some
really good work when he wants to I know
some of it looks a little messy and a
lot of his best work was dependent on a
good colorist but I think people are too
hard on the guy now I'm gonna get back
to more restaurant rants because man
that chucky cheese video took off just a
quick reminder before you go that I post
my videos a day early on patreon and
give exclusive behind-the-scenes content
and patron exclusive videos please
consider becoming a patron it really
helps me out if you want a more
short-term way to support the channel
you can check out my merch and the links
in the description we have t-shirts
phone cases posters mugs pillows baby
onesies and so much more see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]